whisky im weltraum neue medizinische
laser technologie und 70.000 kilogramm
schwerer wahl gestrandet das sind nur
drei der fünf themen heute in den krieg
zum topf news
rätselhaftes war scherben auf der
westlichen küste alaskas kamen 30 wale
ums leben
und das innerhalb von vier monaten die
wissenschaftler sind erschüttert und
gleichermaßen ratlos was die
todesursache angeht zitat die
wissenschaftler der fischereibehörde und
ihre partner sind sehr besorgt über die
große zahl gestrandeter wale im
westlichen golf von alaska in den
letzten monaten so der mol
wissenschaftler terry jones --die
us-börsen veröffentlichte dieses bild
auf dem bild ist ein riesiger finnwal
der auch noch unerklärten gründen
gestrandet ist zu sehen die kleinen
dunklen flecken um herum
das sind übrigens grizzlybären das
sollte eine ungefähre größten
vorstellung das war als möglich machen
ein finnwal wiegt bis zu 70.000
kilogramm
wenn ihr euch jetzt 30 gestrandete wale
vorstellt die sind zwar nicht alle so
riesig aber dennoch groß und schwer
könnt ihr euch dann eine mögliche
todesursache vorstellen eine die solche
tonnenschwere riesen niederstreckt rund
4000 tote innerhalb von 24 stunden
der grund die luftverschmutzung aufgrund
dieser sterben in china tatsächlich alle
24 stunden so viele menschen ein
immobilienkonzern und ein ingenieurbüro
kämpfen jetzt dagegen an zitat wir haben
der regierung vertraut dass sich durch
greifen weil ihr aber keine
ausreichenden anstrengungen sehen wollen
wir dieses dringende probleme schneller
angehen so der erhob ingenieur jim eton
ihre problemlösung sieht folgendermaßen
aus unter einem verdeckt wird die
dreckige luft von unten angesaugt auf
dem weg nach oben gefiltert und dann von
oben nach unten gepostet jeder der
darunter steht bekommt also gefilterte
luft zum atmen mit ihrer problemlosen
treten allerdings tritt ein weiteres
problem auf die ganze apparatur benötigt
nämlich zu viel energie
das heißt bei der versorgung der
apparatur wird mehr luft verschmutzt als
gesäubert gute idee aber mal sehen ob
sie so umsetzbar wird
monströser brocken im all die sonde dawn
hat außergewöhnliche bilder vom planeten
cs zur erde geschickt auf diesen
aufnahmen konnten die forscher einen
gewaltigen brocken ausmachen zitat viele
der oberflächenstrukturen die wir in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten entdeckt
haben sind einzigartig und rätselhaft so
andreas nathues vom max planck institut
für sonnensystemforschung in götting zu
solchen rätselhaften strukturen zählt
auch der kürzlich auf zaehres gefundene
berg er ist sechs kilometer hoch und an
der breitesten stelle misst dieser rund
zwölf kilometer experten versuchen jetzt
mehr über diesen 500 millionen kilometer
von der erde entfernten berg in
erfahrung zu bringen
zitat einiges was wir sehen haben wir
außer auf der erde noch nie so im
sonnensystem entdeckt sagt baumann vom
dlr
gebündeltes licht erleichtert
krebsgewebe am gehirn zu entfernen
operative eingriffe in der nähe des
gehirns sind trotz des medizinischen
fortschritts noch lange keine routine
operation gerade deshalb ist es wichtig
spezielle hilfsinstrumente nutzen zu
können ein solches allerdings völlig
neues instrument konnten jetzt chirurgen
aus london erfolgreich einsetzen das
hilfsinstrument ist relativ simpel zu
benennen gebündeltes licht also ein
leser und mit hilfe dieses lasers
konnten die chirurgen krebsgewebe von
gesunden unterscheiden
und das während der operation zitat das
gibt uns einen offensichtlichen vorteil
bei der geschwindigkeit so der
neurochirurg barbara wackers aber warum
ohne diese neue lasertechnologie müsse
man weiterhin parallel zur operation 13
proben in ein labor bringen um zu wissen
ob das gewebe befallen ist oder nicht
wenn diese technologie ausgereift ist
und ein fester bestandteil der
krankenhaus inventare wird kann man wohl
von einem großen schritt in der
chirurgie sprechen
der japanische whisky hersteller st
schickt der iss alkohol
die besatzung der internationalen
raumstation iss musste jetzt schon ein
paar mal auf ihre ration lieferungen
warten auf die alkohol lieferung hat
wohl keiner mehrere hundert kilometer
über der erde sehen richtig gewartet
trinken darf die besatzung nämlich
nichts also nichts alkoholisches aber
warum um alles auf der welt soll auf
einer international forschungsstation im
weltall whisky gestapelt werden
eine h 2b rakete ist am mittwoch mit der
flüssigen fracht losgeschickt worden mit
an bord hatte die rakete natürlich auch
noch für die astronautin astronauten
brauchbare nahrungsmittelrationen der
whisky soll jetzt rund 365 tage also ein
jahr im all bleiben und reifenexperten
des herstellers rechnen mit einer
geschmacklichen veränderung ihre zehn
proben werden nach der reife zahlt im
all sehnsüchtig erwartet und dann
genauer unter die lupe genommen
also immer mal gespannt ob in der
schwerelosigkeit gerechter whisky besser
oder schlechter schmeckt geschmäcker
sind ja verschieden dass es bekannt und
bekannt ist auch dass computer immer
schneller werden wie diese aber 1000 mal
schneller werden können erfahrt ihr im
video hier oben
genau dazu rap und zum blog geht es hier
unten und was glaubt ihr bringt es die
menschheit weiter wenn man whisky ins
all schießt es gab ja schon mehrere
seltsamer experimente dieser letzten
endes doch zu etwas nützlich war
schreibt uns eure meinung dazu gerne mal
in die kommentare und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran